[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous nouvelle
formule de 5 à 10 à l'occasion des
municipales nous allons recevoir
bertrand caruge et mois en alternance
les candidats aux élections de 2020
chaque candidat aura cinq minutes pour
s'exprimer ce matin nous recevons serge
cette rose bonjour bonjour mon joueur
favori
vous êtes élu de l'opposition aux 3 il
est pour les élections municipales de
2001 vous êtes la tête de liste du
rassemblement démocratique il est c'est
bien ça c'est bien ça vous succédez
adriers altus oui quelles raisons vous
pousse à reprendre le flambeau pour
quelles sont vos motivations
mais vous savez c'est d'abord une
décision collective nous avons posé la
question à la tête de liste du 2014 qui
ne voulait pas se représenter
et donc nous en font tous de table pour
savoir qui serait le candidat le plus
approprié pour cette candidature j'ai eu
l'honneur humblement d'être désigné et
j'ai eu un moment de solitude avant de
prendre ma décision parce que vous savez
quand on part en engagement ça veut dire
qu'une mairie a besoin d'une
mobilisation personnelle mais une
jubilation c'est d'avoir avec moi
l'équipe qui poursuivaient et de
nouveaux qui nous rejoint face au maire
quels sont vos arguments
est ce que vous comptez sur l'usure du
pouvoir pour accéder à la main vous
savez nous on vient pas contre quelqu'un
on vient d'abord proposé un projet ce
projet on l'a portée en 2014 on va le
poursuivre et il ya un certain nombre de
dax sur lesquelles on voit on va
accélérer et convaincant tout cas la
population nous rejoindre parce que
lui-même il constate bien qu' il ya des
choses qui fonctionnent pas je rappelle
que cette liste était monté à 4 2014 par
des anciens élus qui ont mené en écho et
l'habilité donc ça veut dire que quelque
part il ya une défiance où il ya un
mécontentement en tout cas de son action
et il y en a remarqué qu' effectivement
depuis 2014 il y à une vraie opposition
qui existe qui n'a jamais existé
d'ailleurs vous voyez bien regardez bien
trois oppositions sont mortes au fur et
à mesure qu'elle n'essaie elles ont été
absorbés dans son chai monsieur le maire
aujourd'hui donc ce qui veut dire que
soit six personnes étaient à la
recherche de postes en tout cas moi je
ne sais pas quelle a été la motivation
aujourd'hui on a remarqué que certaines
choses ont fonctionné enfin quels sont
les axes de votre compagne lead
principale mesure on peut en avoir deux
par exemple les deux principales mesures
de votre campagne sur les chantiers sont
énormes et vous savez il ya la
revitalisation du bourg le centre au
bout du chemin
quinze mille véhicules passent on a des
soucis de circulation monsieur le maire
à un moment donné ici de faire changer
les sens de circulation
et sans concertation ce qui a entraîné
une montée de boucliers des habitants
n'ont plus joué il a reculé dessus bon
je dis il ya des sens qui sont donnés je
crois qu on juxtapose des choses on va à
la va-vite en oubliant que derrière il
ya des projets privés qui arrive vous
voyez mais qu'à l'entrée du bourg
aujourd'hui il ya deux projets qui sont
sortis un projet de supermarché
discutable parce que bon l'implantation
était à voir et à vérifier et il est un
projet nous trop bouger en face d'un
espace à rénover entièrement quartier
rénové qui magasinent sur lequel il
bouge et qui arrivait donc il est tout
seul toustou s'externalise vous me direz
partout ailleurs c'est la même chose
mais aujourd'hui alain beaud qui est un
beau traversant sur lequel il ya une
réflexion à bras donc ça va être un gros
brochet dessus
autre projet l'assainissement en un gros
problème c'est l'assainissement tous les
quartiers ne sont pas ne sont pas
branchés en assainissement dont
l'encours travail à faire dessus
terminer cet assainissement il notamment
vous savez on parlait du bout à l'entrée
du bourg vous avez de beaux points avec
des belles statues mais figurez vous
qu'il ya une milhas qui s'écoule et qu'
ils n'ont certains quartiers je pense à
la wii 9
je pense aussi un magazine parce que
quand la mois quand il ya le mot la
montée de désobéir il n'arrive pas à
ogeu t-il à rejeter les effluents
donc vous voyez on a vraiment un travail
et de choses de ce côté vous avez comme
ambition de faire des trois îles et la
capitale du sud et du bien vivre
ensemble
ce n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui il ne
fait pas bon vivre
3 il est si on regarde il fait bon vivre
très zélé mais il fait bon vivre aussi
aux anses d'arlet ils m'ont vu dans deux
des titres aux communes donc on n'a pas
de particularités mais aujourd'hui il y
a des éléments de deux cohabitations
qu'il faut sur lesquels qu'il faut qu'on
travaille un des éléments de faire vivre
ensemble des populations sans mettre les
gens à côté des autres je pense qu'il y
a un travail à faire alors pourquoi une
capitale capitale du sud parce que nous
sommes traversant diamant 11 dans les
eaux salées
toutes ces communes passe par nous mais
ne s'arrête pas ou alors on revient
effectivement quand il ya quand il ya
les fêtes
mais aujourd'hui on a besoin de jouer ce
rôle de capitale sur le monde ce rôle de
charnière entre autres que c'est entre
ces différentes populations si elle
sainte-rose je vous remercie
bonne journée aller coûte de nos
programmes